hey there i'm marine wilson and i'm reza
aslan and i'm trying to be a better man
doesn't that mean you're just trying to
be a better person no no i mean
literally i'm trying to be a better man
like man like a man man like a man man
i'm not saying i know what that that
actually means well let's find out let's
ask a woman perfect
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
so rain of the many many things that we
have in common with each other one of
them is that we are uh both fathers to
boys yeah yeah raising boys four boys
between us yeah one for me three for you
do you want to give me one of yours and
let's just split it i might i might
think about it i got twins i mean
they're kind of interchangeable you can
have one of them don't they hit on each
other a lot too there's a lot of
punching a lot of punching in my in my
family
so is that you know we're going to talk
about toxic masculinity and manhood and
stuff like that does it bother you all
the punching or is that just natural the
punching or how do you get through to be
honest little kids hitting each other
you know it it it affects my wife more
than it affects me like jessica when
when jasper and cyrus you know fight
each other i mean physically fight each
other jessica breaks down like she just
starts weeping she doesn't know how to
respond to it and i'm like all right
boys like go to opposite corners because
i guess as a man i just think well sure
you get frustrated and you punch isn't
that what you do kind of wired and i
think for her
it's just so outside of her experience
and so yeah this is this is part of this
issue about what it means to be a man
i know my son his favorite thing to do
and has always been his favorite thing
to do is to wrestle with me he's 15 now
and he's he's not close to winning but
it's it's it's starting to hurt a little
bit more but he loves to wrestle he
needs that he needs that uh the contact
and the
um
i i don't know what it is the resistance
and and something about subverting me
there's a there's a little bit of some
elemental greek stuff there saturn
overthrowing the father there's some
medical kind of [ __ ] going on he loves
the fact that he's a better guitar
player than me now he loves to lord it
over me and um it's a natural part of of
manhood but it can certainly go too far
yeah and
for both of us you know we we like to
think of ourselves as
worldly and and progressive um i know
that you know with jasper and cyrus my
wife and i went out of our way not to
give them sort of traditional boys toys
and yet
that's all they wanted all they wanted
was like cars and trucks and we're like
wha what is this like we didn't do this
right we would give them dolls and be
like isn't this a cute doll you should
play with it and they'd be like uh yeah
can i beat this doll up
what is this turn it into a gun yeah
everything gets turned into a weapon
is that just a boy thing what what are
we what are we doing here this is tough
so
i i grew up in a home where uh my dad
was very gentle
and very kind
um you know he has his flaws we've had
our issues we have our issues
but
i didn't get a kind of uh any kind of
toxic masculinity stuff kind of thrust
on me and i know that that can be
incredibly debilitating to people uh
that have grown up with that but there
were some aspects of his manhood and the
manhood that i inherited both from him
and from men around me men on television
men in our greater family which were
some issues that
i still wrestle with today and that is
i as a man i'm supposed to be
self-sufficient i'm not supposed to need
help from anyone all right i'm not
supposed to ask for help i'm not
supposed to make myself vulnerable i'm
not supposed to
show or reveal my emotions
my flaws my vulnerabilities and this has
been something that i that might my dad
doesn't do he doesn't reveal his
vulnerabilities and it's something that
has
been um an issue with me that i that
i've carried through my life do you have
do you have issues around i mean almost
identical i mean yeah my dad wasn't by
any means sort of a manly man but yes he
never showed any vulnerability he
uh tried never to show any kind of
emotional weakness
um
you know other than the occasional flash
of anger i imagine which is an okay
emotion for men to experience in fact
it's the only emotion that we're allowed
to express and i would say like for me
my my biggest psychological problem and
the thing that i've worked hardest on
uh as a husband
is precisely trying to have you know
more than one emotional reaction to
things i mean i feel like for me sadness
gets expressed as anger confusion gets
expressed as anger uh any vulnerability
that i have comes out as anger your
twitter feed my expresses itself
expresses itself i've noticed as anger
and
um and i yes i think that's that's kind
of
the example that i had when i grew up
i'm sure that's the example that my
father had when he grew up i'm sure
that's the example that many
men have i mean another aspect of toxic
masculinity that does affect me and is
you know i hate to be all woke and use
this language but it's white male
privilege you know like i am so
privileged in every way i'm rich i'm a
celebrity i'm white i'm over six foot
two i'm college educated whatever and i
can't help sometimes but assume the
mantle of like hey i should be listened
to i get to interrupt my opinion counts
more um people are going to look to me
for the answers i'm going to be the
center of things there's a kind of a
entitlement and arrogance there that
kind of comes with the territory that it
takes a lot of work to be
semi-woke to kind of go like hey you
know what can i listen more can i be
humble more can i surrender more and
prove my ignorance more and be an ally
and supporter of people's voices that
are marginalized i know those kind of
that's all that stuff is really cliche
but i find it like
this is something i struggle with and
thank god i have a wife who will point
it out to me like you interrupted points
you interrupted this person you didn't
listen to me you went on and on about
this thing
and she also points out how other people
and you know women too will will kind of
give me extra an extra a megaphone kind
of they turn to you rain did you see how
everyone was like i wonder what rayne
thinks and like you kind of had the
attention of the room and like um
you know you have to watch for that
there's a lot of ego around that so
we're trying
you and i but whether we're succeeding
or not is difficult to know and you said
it perfectly like maybe the best way to
do this is to talk to a woman about it
and so
while you were off on some crazy
adventure uh in in greenland i had an
opportunity to sit down and talk to
somebody that i love somebody that i'd
actually never met uh personally were
like sort of social media friends but
somebody that i've been following for a
really long time her name is liz planck
she's a feminist activist um she's host
of uh vox media's considerate um and
she has gotten a lot of attention for a
book that she's just written called for
the love of men a new vision of mindful
masculinity um and in it she explores
precisely what we're talking about right
now how
damaging traditional ideas of
masculinity have been
not just for men
but for all of us for all of society and
i had an opportunity to not just sit
down and talk to her but i had a chance
to actually bring one of my boys along
too oh no way that's awesome yeah and
here we go
[Music]
i have a master's in gender theory and
i've been thinking about this stuff for
a very long time but i started realizing
that often the rooms uh that i was in
the progressive feminist spaces which
were amazing and where we would have
incredible conversations um
were there were kind of like half of us
missing in those conversations and the
main people who were kind of uh you know
really uh the problem
yeah
or responsibilities we weren't showing
out of the yes there was there seemed to
be an imbalance there and i yeah i joke
that we would just you know always like
wave to the guy in the back and you've
probably been that guy in so many of
those rooms and we all go thank you for
being here thank you for being an ally
um go talk to men and
clearly that has not worked uh so far um
you know i started writing this book
before the 2016 election then donald
trump was elected it was even clear that
we really needed to have a conversation
around masculinity and and around men
and so um i started talking to men
and i started interviewing men and
asking them very simple questions about
masculinity like what uh like what's
hard about being a man
what's hard about being yeah tell me
what's happening being a man um
what's hard about being awoke man
i mean tell me tell me tell me more
what's up i would say that the the most
difficult part for me about
understanding my
male hood and my masculinity
is
um
balancing the expectations
not that society has on me [ __ ] society
but the the expectations that um
that i have on myself
um and especially as a husband and as a
father and as a son
with
um
my desire to kind of brush off those
expectations and
to um
to sort of try to get away from the
binary itself all together you know like
i would say that's for me the hardest
thing about being a man
and what is the main way for you to
express yourself as a man like what does
a man mean to you
it's what almost every man you've asked
this question to says uh
about
creating protection yeah right
and um
and
uh
sort of and prosperity like i feel like
those are the the two burdens that fall
on my shoulder yeah um protection and
prosperity yeah um yeah yeah and they do
uh right the protector provider i i
ideal which is you know
pretty much every society falls on the
shoulders of men and and one of the
things that fascinated me was
how much
i was how angry i was at my own
scholarship and my own education having
been incredibly privileged to be able to
earn a master's degree in gender theory
um already
to see how little i had been taught
about masculinity and how little you
know i hadn't been assigned a single
book about masculinity and what you're
talking about in terms of the provider
protector model um
is actually in
increasingly correlated with increasing
amounts of suicide amongst men right so
in societies where more women work for
example where there's more gender
equality it actually protects men from
from suicide attempts and and dying from
suicide um during times of economic
hardship so you really see during times
of recession 2008 recession or across
europe
we really saw an increase in male
suicides and feminism right gender
equality female empowerment is actually
can be an antidote to
these increasing levels of male suicide
because women
are sharing those responsibilities too
and then we're all providers and we're
all protectors and this year i'm gonna
provide in a more financial way and
you're going to provide by being there
and like making sure our kids don't die
yeah um and
those are obviously equally important
right the person who pays for the book
is just as important as the person who
teaches the kid how to read that book
and actually just buying the book
without having someone being able to
teach it is useless and so we have to
expand these definitions of how we all
are providers and protectors
so that you're able to
still be a man and not have to prove
your masculinity if you're not able to
achieve those expectations that are
truly ideals that that that aren't
always possible for all men to achieve
but to this point of the notion of
expectation it's funny because i i had
to stop and think to myself
you know are the expectations that i
have of myself as a man do they are they
forced upon me by others and the truth
is is no not really i mean i like to
think that they're not
but you say something that's really
interesting which is that women are born
women
but men become men right like we're not
born men we have to like become a man
and so there's something that about
having to earn that status and then
the the moment that it becomes a thing
that you earn
it can also become a thing that you can
lose
and so there's this anxiety about
um
first of all achieving this thing which
is un undefinable and and vague and
um and hard to def hard to sort of
understand anyway and then
recognizing that that thing can be taken
away from you yes um and maybe that's
where some of this anxiety comes from
and it starts very early right and so
that creates so much shame right and
repression of if you show if if you show
weakness it's not that there's something
wrong with society there's something
wrong with you yeah and you're to blame
and not only are you not supposed to
feel that you're not supposed to talk
about it and so
a lot of men and and you know i talk a
lot about male shame in the book
and
the most amount of comments i've i've
received and like you know messages and
you know men particularly sharing with
me um is is this has been able to put a
language on something i've never been
able to understand or no therapist has
been able to even help me understand
that um there's this
there's this shame spiral that not only
yeah makes you feel like well then
you're not a man then if you're not a
man then not you're not worthy of
connection you're not worthy of
belonging you're not worthy of being uh
you know in a partnership and so it
creates this cycle of isolation and
actually what the research finds is that
when men experience this shame and women
experience shame too right of course um
but when men uh tend to experience the
the shame they either do two things
one is isolate so further withdrawing
um and the other one is masculinity
restoring uh activities right so
exactly proving it right prove it you
took it away from me i'm gonna prove it
and if we live in a society where the
way to prove that you're really
masculine is to grab women by the [ __ ]
is to have a lot of guns is to be
dominant talk over other people be
violent be aggressive um of course we
end up with a mass shooting in every
every day in this country of course we
end up with rising suicide rates that
are you know in a state like wyoming for
example where the rate of suicide is the
highest in all of this country 80 of
people who are dying from suicide are
men and so when you're not able right to
restore your masculinity and you're
going into isolation as a way to protect
yourself um you are either
hurting yourself or you're hurting other
people and i don't think either of those
are um productive and neither of those
are um useful ways for men to actually
cope with the struggle and the pain that
they're feeling
hey milk shakers rain
wilson here and listen
i need to have meditation as a part of
my life or i go kind of loco in the
cabeza
i also have to work out
i play a lot of tennis hydration has to
be a priority so one stick of this
liquid iv that i've been trying recently
in 16 ounces of water it hydrates us
faster and more efficiently than water
alone oh come on why do we need
to put flavor in water but whatever i'm
gonna try it out
it is no exaggeration to say that i am
obsessed with liquid iv i drink like
five of these a day i actually have a
bowl
in my kitchen
full of all the different flavors
there's like strawberry and there's
guava
uh there's a lemon lime one that i
really like passion fruit that's my
wife's favorite so here's what you're
gonna do you're gonna grab your liquid
iv in bulk
nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use the code word
milkshake
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today using promo code milkshake all you
got to do is go to liquid
i v the letters iv
dot com
put the code in milkshake 25 off i'm
telling you man i feel
a million times better now that i'm
actually hydrated instead of basically
substituting coffee for water which is
what i normally do healthy snacks have a
very bad reputation for a good reason
most of them don't taste very good and
they don't fill you up and they don't
satisfy your cravings
this particular episode of metaphysical
milkshake is sponsored by monk pack
who makes snacks that taste like great
tasting sugary treats but with one gram
of sugar or less they're only 150
calories and they're great for anyone
who's following the keto lifestyle
they're also the perfect snack for
anyone who's just trying to eat better
or cut back on sugar and carbs without
sacrificing taste i've got right here on
my desk right now the coconut cocoa chip
man this is
i mean i like a lot of these flavors but
the coconut cocoa chip i can't say
enough about i'm gonna open this up
right now i'm gonna eat it while rain
talks they've got that perfect balance
of sweet and salty and they've got a
crunch from whole nuts and seeds but
they still manage to be soft and chewy
you just try them trust me you're going
to love them they come in delicious
flavors like sea salt dark chocolate
caramel sea salt and my very favorite
peanut butter dark chocolate try it for
yourself you'll see we have a special
deal for our listeners you get 20 off
your first purchase of any monk pack
product
all you got to do is visit monkpack.com
and enter our code milkshake at checkout
and i just want to say yes it's gross
that i'm talking with my mouth full but
what am i gonna do i love my monk pack
monk pack is so confident in their
product it's backed by a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee so if you don't
like it for any reason they'll exchange
the product or refund your money
whichever you prefer so to get started
go to monkpack.com that's
m-u-n-k-p-a-c-k.com select any product
then enter the code milkshake at
checkout to save what
20 percent off your purchase monk pack
delicious nutritious food you can count
on and we thank you monk pack for
sponsoring the podcast
[Music]
i want to talk a little bit more
deeply about
ideas of manhood where they come from
the roots of manhood how how we even
understand it the ancient greeks had
this idea um called andrea which is
essentially the the the greek term for
maleness it's b it's where we get the
very concept for us
and
for them
it had a very clear
definition it meant
brawn it meant audacity
but what was
really remarkable about this idea is
that it wasn't tied to a gender in other
words it was a term that could apply to
men or women i mean some
incredibly heroic
mythical female characters in in uh
greek stories in greek mythology
were described as having andrea this
notion of brawn uh this notion of
of um audacity in battle
but we get our concept of virility not
from the greeks but from the romans
virility for the romans which comes from
this roman term virilitas um was all
about uh self-control
self-control moderation right that
reigning in your power that's what
virility meant
and
i guess what what i what i find
fascinating about this whole thing is
that these are separate things that
maleness and virility
are different things virility also could
be as applied to men and to women
and yet
i think what's happened in western
society
is that
this greco-roman idea
of andrea maleness and virilitas
virility
became
sort of
married together right and it became
this idea that we now refer to as
masculinity an idea that women are no
longer
allowed to take any part in right we
don't refer to women as
um
you know masculine we don't refer to
certainly not a in a complementary way
we don't refer to women as virile i mean
that's just a word we don't use for
women even though again yeah the word
the concept is not gender right i'm just
curious kind of in your research on this
and your academic work
how much of the way that we understand
maleness
has to do with
the kind of historic ways in which it's
been described and presented to us i
think that where
to me as a as a person who's been you
know researching and reporting on this
i've just seen so much
uh comfort and uh encouragement for
girls showing masculine energy and right
and so we're saying uh to girl we think
it's gonna be a tomboy it's humble you
can girls who code and girls who become
engineers we're giving her a science kid
instead of a barbie doll and that's
badass right and so a lot of
the last i think five or ten years of
feminism particularly but especially the
last five years where there's been a
focus on feminism in in career and in
the workplace um it's been this idea of
be more assertive
take command of a situation
don't apologize right these are
masculine traditionally masculine right
ideas and obviously not all women have
the latitude to do that if you're a
black woman in the workplace you do not
have the same attitude as a white woman
in the workplace um
but there's an encouragement and a and a
and a celebration of that right
so there's a celebration of a girl
playing with a monster truck but there's
no celebration of a boy playing with a
doll right and there's actually a lot of
fear around that and and there's i
document it in the book it's it's
in places like new york with people who
define themselves as progressives and
feminists um i you know talk about this
man i was talking to who was saying i
love you know my my sister my my
daughter i brought her to this uh you
know dance and it's all about feminism
and i'm super excited about female
empowerment but then you know my son was
holding a bouquet of flowers and i and i
and i told him like give it to your
sister
and
i don't think that
that this is about shaming parents i
don't think that this is parents trying
to hurt their boys they're trying to
protect their boys but the problem is
not the flowers right the problem is not
the nail polish the problem is not the
dolls um giving something that cries to
a boy rather than something that kills
right why are we more comfortable with a
boy holding a toy gun than a doll um
this is the system that's that's that's
hurting them and parents are just trying
to protect their their kids yeah i guess
that's what i'm really interested in is
is that system i think you're right a
lot of it has to do with protection yeah
a lot of it has to do with the fact that
fathers want their sons to to be in
their image and this is what they were
talking about about what it means to be
men and so that's how they think it it's
supposed to be um
so
it's about the way in which
we learn for sure
it's about culture there's no question
about that
something internal is is i think getting
us in this kind of feedback loop
but
it becomes extraordinarily difficult if
you can't sort of
trace with confidence
where this definition comes from to
disrupt that definition right so much of
this is coming from misogyny right
internalized misogyny where the only
reason why it's not cool for a guy to be
a nurse but it's cool for a woman to be
an engineer is because we devalue what
women are and what women do and we
devalue that work um i talk in the book
i mean they're only 10 of teachers um
are male 1
and a lot of people will think well
women are just more inclined to go into
that profession women are more nurturing
uh they have more patience they raise
children so of course they're more
likely going to into education
but then you realize that education at
its uh inception was a male profession
the only reason why we have all women
and we had women become teachers was
because the government realized that
they could pay them less right and so
then they started creating stereotypes
around men being drunks men being
pedophiles men you know you can't really
trust them so it became you know a
basically an essentially female
profession and i don't think that that's
helping us right i don't think that and
it's hurting us in in and you know
gender is just one obviously prism and
then you add all the other things this
is a conversation that needs to be in
intersectional um black boys i mean two
or three percent of teachers are are
black men and uh for a black boy to see
have one single one
male black teacher
over the course of it could be in second
grade and then they never see a black uh
a teacher again
it makes them 38 less likely to drop out
of school in college right so this is
there's so much potential i think male
potential that's being lost so many men
who would want to be teachers would want
to be caretakers who want to be social
workers who are interested in all of
these professions who are getting the
message in a million different kinds of
ways that this is not for them um and
and that starts again i mean
i i asked one of the my
just most heartbreaking questions i
asked men was what was a toy that you
were told you weren't allowed to play
with as a boy which was a toy that you
wanted to play with right and that just
is such an i think toys and playing and
thinking about yourself as a child is is
really who you are right and there's
something about being able to connect
with that inner child that's so
we we really don't do
and so many men just yeah remembered
exactly they had vivid memories of
obviously easy bake ovens so many easy
bake ovens were denied um
uh one man recalled here overhearing his
parents uh arguing over the fact that he
wanted kitchen tools for christmas and
hearing that again that shame right
there's something wrong with me there's
not something wrong you when you're a
kid you don't understand
you internalize everything right and and
one man also recalled like a little
shopping cart he just loved this little
shopping cart and he came back one night
and his dad and all his friends had
destroyed it
and it's just like acts of humiliation
and these acts of restoring right this
is who you are this is you can't be this
so i i thought that instead of keeping
this in the in the more sort of
theoretical uh conversation about what
it means to be a man and and how to to
raise young boys into men i would just
ask my young boy i love it so uh
one of my many sons
one of my many many children hey cyrus
hi hi would you mind joining us for a
little bit so can you start by telling
us your name i'm sorry with david aslan
and i am in
second grade i think so the first
question that i have for you is
um
you have a lot of friends who are boys
and a lot of friends who are girls what
do you think what do would you say is
the difference between boys and girls
is it okay if i something say something
kind of inappropriate yes you can say
anything you'd like okay great it is
enough
it's so anyway goats have vaginas and
boys don't and boys have penises and
girls don't however
don't you didn't you have a friend
who
in in uh preschool started out as a boy
and then chose to be a girl
well technically not chose mmm tell us
about that well there was this born
inside simon in preschool he he thought
he was
a
girl oh so he changed his name to grace
and then he tried to change his name to
batgirl
but that did not work people did not
start calling her batgirl but they did
call her grace yeah and i and i cut for
god a couple of times and called her
simon yeah but that's really interesting
so okay so girls have sometimes girls
have vaginas and boys have penises
that's good but that can't be all
because then simon became grace but
still had a penis do you think there's
anything else that that
separates girls from boys what would you
think how would you describe the
differences between boys and
girls like to
have long hair oh
do you know boys with long hair yeah oh
well like myself well then that's that
can't be it what else what else do you
think
i have no idea yeah neither do i that's
exactly
that's what liz and i are sitting here
trying to figure this out yeah we needed
your help um
are there things in your mind so just
your opinion
are there things that you think
are only for girls and things that are
only for boys no
no you don't feel that way no yeah
do you think other other your friends
think that way
some of them and
and for some reason they're surprised i
like pink a lot yeah
your favorite color for most of your
life until quite recently was what
purple purple pink and it's still purple
pink and blue
[Music]
especially blue because like i think
i like this i like i could blue jelly
beans i like
the color blue i like basically a lot of
things blue so has anyone ever told you
boys don't do that when you've tried to
do something well maybe once or twice
but not technically and what were you
doing
um
i don't remember anymore you don't
remember um sometimes i've noticed that
some of your friends
uh like at school when they play games
they play kind of violent games don't
they yeah
can you tell us a little bit about that
like what kinds of games do they oh i'm
basically the only one in the school who
never ever plays vinyl in games jeffrey
who's now in my class this
year last year used to place
to play a game actually about snipers
and guns
and
and you and it
goes like this you you un unlock
treasure chests and there's snipers and
guns in them
how come you don't like those kinds of
games honey because you're mean
yeah
do you think that those are games that
mostly boys play or do girls play them
too
um
pretty much mostly boys how come you
think
[Music]
i don't know how to explain it
and what would you say to um a boy who
feels like he can't do certain things
because he was told that boys don't do
that what would you because you you
don't listen to those
how would you what advice would you give
him
i would give him to
i would give him advice like
um
don't listen to
whoever this guy that guy is who's
being mean to you mm-hmm
and what if he says well it hurts my
feelings i feel like i should just do
what he says
you
help them out
oh that's interesting
so help out the person who's being mean
maybe there there's something wrong with
that
help out both people yeah that's very
true right because most people who are
hurting
need some help
folks listen up like many of you i
avoided going to the doctor during the
pandemic i really did i skipped my
yearly physical i skipped my dental
cleaning but now everything is opening
up and it's time to catch up on regular
health care so just download the free
zoc doc app the easiest way to find a
great doctor and instantly book an
appointment you can search for local
doctors who take your insurance you can
read verified patient reviews book an
appointment do an in-person or video
chat whether you need a primary care
physician a dentist a dermatologist a
psychiatrist eye doctor any specialist
zocdoc has you covered so go to
zocdoc.com jesus christ try saying that
three times fast
go to zocdoc.com
zocdoc makes healthcare easy now is the
perfect time to prioritize your health
so go to zocdoc.com
milkshake download the zocdoc app
sign up for free and book a top-rated
doctor many are available as soon as
today that's z-o-c-d-o-c dot com slash
milkshake
zack talk
folks no matter how you're feeling about
getting back out there there's no
denying that it's gonna be an adjustment
when the world gets too loud something
that i love to do is create my own
soundtrack by popping in my raycon
wireless earbuds as soon as i go running
i stick in my recons if i'm walking the
dogs
it allows me to listen to my playlist to
my podcasts and it helps ground center
and focus my day sometimes when i'm like
focusing on writing and i just need to
zone out i pop in these raycons the
world around me just goes away and it's
just me my music and my work ray cons
are the best way to listen they come
with a bunch of gel tips for your
comfort and unlike some other brands
they don't stick out of your ears
i'm not going to name names raycons have
a 32
battery life so you can listen to what
you want when you want for a really
really super long time and they start at
half the price of other premium audio
brands but they sound just as good
raycons come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee so you really can't lose give
them a try you'll see exactly what i
mean you can create your own soundtrack
with raycon
right now
metaphysical milkshake listeners can get
15 off their recon order at by
com slash milkshake that's by raycon dot
com slash
milkshake to save fifteen percent on ray
cons
by raycon dot com slash
milkshake
i think cyrus indicates a really
interesting trend which is that
our ideas of of masculinity and our
expectations of of men and male hood
are shifting pretty rapidly when it
comes to um generations so
only 22 percent of men under the age of
30
say that they have a positive view or a
very positive view of masculinity
um 29 between the ages of 30 and 44. but
then once you start getting a little bit
older right once you start getting to 45
to 64 it's 41
of men 65 and older it's 48
of men
um
so it does seem like
men are
increasingly
um ambivalent about
masculinity and everything that that
comes with it so
do you have hope do you feel like
you know things are changing when you
look into the future i mean minus again
the you know the plessy grabber in chief
but when you look into the to the future
do you think
do you do you see a a time in which
these ideas of masculinity that are so
um i know you don't like the term toxic
but so destructive to society will
eventually fade away i'm interested in a
conversation where we talk about where
men are safe to talk about whether
they're enjoying the system we're in
right now and where we could celebrate
masculinity and we could celebrate boys
and men but you know choose which ones
we're celebrating and which were which
ones were glamorizing and give them more
options so that young boys aren't
growing up saying i don't want to be a
man that makes me sad i mean that that
you know that's not the point of
feminism right the point of feminism is
you know we're seeing the future is
female we're seeing
literally entire aisles at the bookstore
of uh books that are meant to empower
young girls and give them more
a multitude of things and roles that
they can be in the world
there's no where's that aisle for boys
and
where's that latitude and that potential
and and us uplifting supporting and
protecting boys a lot of these
conversations can be counterproductive
if we leave out half of us out of these
conversations
[Music]
okay lightning round yeah when do you
feel most connected with the universe
i want to say
i feel most connected to the universe
when
my
actions
are aligned
with my soul that's good that's good
what is one thing that you hate
i hate hate i really do is the only
thing i let myself hate
what's one thing you know for sure i
mean i want to say the one thing i know
for sure is that i don't know anything
for sure what gender is your soul
it's just purple
i don't know what what gender that is
and then finally what is your life's big
question
i think a lot about why am i here
that's a big one
liz planck we love you thank you so much
for the love of men
awesome book you're an awesome person i
love you thank you so much for all that
you're doing thank you for everything
that you're doing so sweet to my boys
can i become your baby do you need a
nanny um because i will i just want to
eat them up yeah it's pretty delicious
lovely lovely soul
[Music]
wow what a great interview that was so
amazing to hear and your son is
a brilliant be adorable i know vagina i
mean how cute is that uh what so what
what was that like hearing your son
engaging in this conversation yeah thank
you for for asking that um i left that
recording studio and and
it was great because liz was so
she was just so praising of the way that
i had you know raised cyrus and i don't
know there was something about having
a an objective person and particularly a
woman and particularly somebody who's
you know studying masculinity
basically look at me and say
you know what you're doing a pretty good
job it made me feel so good
because it is a struggle as we've talked
about it is a struggle i mean there are
there are moments where
cyrus shows vulnerability and i have to
keep myself from saying
don't be such a baby don't you know why
are you reacting that way you're
overreacting you know you're being too
emotional which is all the things that i
was told right which resulted in this
you know shaming this garbage human that
i am now um
and i feel like
i felt like wow maybe i'm doing an okay
job and what does it mean i think truly
what it means in the end is this notion
that
as a dad
what i'm
meant to do
is allow my son to just simply be the
fullest version of himself
to not try to make him be something else
other than he is because
he is just naturally
vulnerable and emotional and
and i guess my job is to just simply not
stifle that you know that's the best
thing i could do as a dad to a son and
who knows what the vision of what
masculine or the male role is going to
be 20 30 years from now that'll be
really interesting to see where this
goes yeah it's changed so much from now
from what it was in the 1950s i don't
know
something to think about
okay metaphysical milkshake fans it's
time for your favorite segment of the
show and ours when we get to listen to
listener voicemails
[Music]
listen a lot of you a lot of you guys
have a lot of questions yourselves and
you got a lot of answers to the
questions that we ask it's very easy to
join us on the podcast you could go to
our speakpipespeakpike.com
metaphysical milkshake
leave us a voicemail based on one of the
questions that we're asking or if you
want to actually come on the show like
be with me and rain it's so easy all you
gotta do is leave a rating and review on
apple podcast telling us what your
life's big question is or answering one
of our big questions take a screenshot
of it tag us on instagram at
metaphysical milkshake and the next
thing you know you're chilling with me
in rain
yeah easy
yo that's all it takes and for this
episode uh with liz planck you know what
does it mean to be a man
you know the idea of masculinity in the
modern world we've got a few callers in
um and we'd love to hear from you and
we'd love to hear from them the first
call is from doug let's hear what doug
has got to say okay what does it mean to
be a man
wanting to change the climate to make
sure that the kids are all right
i am a man my pronouns are he and him
and i believe very fervently that we
need to
as men abandon the field of leadership
to women
women seem to be doing a better job all
over the world in a leading
on
uh
climate
the changes we need to make as a society
to make sure that the kids are all right
specifically i think we need to
look to indigenous women and black women
to
leadership positions to help get us
through the crisis that white males
created
and
i'm very attracted to
the notion of seven generations
which is an indigenous concept
of thinking about every decision from
the standpoint of
how is this going to impact our children
seven generations from now if we can
even think that
far ahead
if we could do that
we would save the climate and things
would be great for our kids
yeah let the let the women rule fun fact
here there are only 22 countries in the
world where women
serve as heads of state did you know
that there are 119
countries who have never had including
us in the united states who have never
had
a female head of state and yet
just look at the last two years
let's look at kovid right
female-led
countries
yeah new zealand like new zealand but
other female-led countries as well
overwhelmingly
had fewer deaths per population
and handled kovid better than male-led
countries so you know doug's not just uh
[ __ ] around here he's he's absolutely
right we need to have more women in
leadership roles we need to give the
reigns of leadership to women
uh and uh and you know otherwise we're
just you know we're all screwing
ourselves
i'm glad he brought up uh
you know
women of color uh
taking the reins because i will say that
you know women have been doing a pretty
fantastic job around the world but not
in the united states
not marjorie taylor greene and lauren
beaubert
these women are more crazy and more
right-wing than any guy possibly could
be it's like come on
but isn't that a step in feminism that
the women are just as fascistic
as
the men
hey women we can be fascists too yeah
you know i hate getting partisan but it
really is true and um i don't know why
men get defensive around this all the
time you bring this up and so many men
just get so riled up and hot around the
collar like you're demeaning me you're
degrading me as a man like how dare you
and um
just so prickly and defensive and it's
like guys
it's okay we tried white men tried we
gave it a good shot last four five
hundred years actually last four or five
thousand years and um
time to just move on past the baton no
big deal still play you could still golf
put your feet on the silly you could put
your feet up eat some fried chicken
enjoy the game all right we got one more
caller here another man this is great i
want to hear from men yes about what it
means to be a man uh this is tim what do
you got to say tim my name is tim i'm a
protestant christian i live in nashville
so because i'm a protestant christian it
means i look at everything through
a biblical lens because i believe in
biblical uh uh
infability um and inerrancy and things
like that but anyways um trying to be
fast okay um when i was 25 and 31 now uh
was the first time i was really exposed
to the idea of of what it meant to be a
man and a a former pastor of mine was
hosting something called a great man
event which was four nights um four
tuesday nights here in nashville where
we talk about uh what it means to be a
man uh what god has called us to do as
man um
the things that were expect that he
expects of us uh those things were
really uh
at a simplified perspective um you know
a man
a man does manly things is the word to
use which is providing protecting and
leading his family uh man tends his
flock which means
he's responsible and disciplined and
takes care of the things that he needs
to do there's a couple others but
that was a really a changing point in my
life and
it was really significant to me and i
would love to talk about it more and uh
be a part of your podcast i love
theology and talking about that and
religion
and i've really enjoyed your show and it
would be great to hear from you tim that
was very well said and i know reza is
going to have a lot to say because it
has to do with the bible which is one of
your areas of expertise um i want to
jump in thank you for that very
sensitive and thoughtful
uh question
posed through a christian lens but
really
accessible to everyone believer and
non-believer alike i appreciated that
very much um
i think that the the only thing that i
would say is i i say tim i say amen to
you
um
provider and protector and leader of the
flock i think we see reza doing that
with his 87 kids
it is a flock you know when you think
about providing and protecting your
flock
i think this can often be
misconstrued and
redefined as you know men are in charge
men rule
what the man says goes
protecting can be militant
um
as opposed to can we nurture our flock
and support
and
uh lift up
and you know essentially
um if instead of viewing jesus as this
kind of god man son of god floating on a
cloud if we look at jesus as someone
whose actions can be emulated
then we as men can
emulate jesus
with our families
i'm not saying we wash their feet
necessarily
but
caretake in a loving
manner that might be missing from
today's
view on masculinity
wow that was beautifully said thank you
no that's exactly what i was going to
say i mean look this is a it's a
widespread phenomenon right not just in
america not just among you know
protestants this idea that our concept
of male hood comes from the bible which
is can be a little bit problematic as as
you know the caller himself kind of
admitted a little bit um
you know the bible says that uh
the man is to the family like jesus is
to the church and it's a beautiful idea
and it's supposed to make you think oh
well then the job of the man is to be
humble and self-sacrificing and
compassionate and merciful because those
are the things that jesus was but
oftentimes what it becomes is oh that
means the man is god
the man plays the role of messiah in the
family
and
that kind of mentality i think is
prevalent
amongst christian households you know
not just in the us but across
the world and you know like you said it
just right is that that that can be
extremely problematic and also let's not
forget
that when the bible says that
you know we should follow god's design
for true masculinity
okay but that was the design of
masculinity 3000 years ago the world is
a little bit different
now and yet we still see it right that
the man is supposed to provide that the
man is supposed to protect well
i mean my wife provides just fine and
she protects pretty well you know and
it doesn't make me less of a man to be
like yeah it's cool my wife takes care
of me that's not a big deal and it also
doesn't make me less of a man that i do
all the cooking and cleaning uh in our
household because my wife sucks at both
in fact
literally this woman liter burned water
two separate times like she she didn't
burn water once rain
she burned water wait no jesus did jesus
burned water
right she says i think he turned water
into wine if my wife water and wine uh i
think you're right too in uh reframing
uh the man's role as protector provider
because two three four thousand years
ago yes we had to put you know women
were bearing children and raising and
nurturing the children and and cooking
in the cave and men were out with the
hunt and had the spears and the stronger
upper body strength so
that's all well and good but it's 20 21
and we're all watching netflix so what
does that mean
now
yeah but great question tim and i loved
uh how you phrased it and um
i unlike reza would love to see people
from both sides of the political
spectrum and religious spectrums
uh be
uh commenting and uh
con consulting on these life's biggest
possible questions
and you know i'm teasing reza because i
know you want the same thing
you can find us on social
at reza aslan and rayne wilson hashtag
metaphysical the show is on twitter at
metamilkpodcast it's on instagram at
metaphysical milkshake and uh you can
include liz in the convo she can be
found at feminist stabulous so that's
feminist and then add an a-b-u-l-o-u-s
feminist fabulous at feminist fabulous
and pick up her book for the love of men
while you're at it buy it do it tell
your friends to buy it tell them right
now oh was i being toxically male in
that i was being really like by alpha
all of a sudden maybe that's the dwight
schrute in me i don't know
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold it was additionally
executive produced by goal reese lucina
and daryush brezwella no thaft it was
produced by amy estroy and rebecca
lehrer of the mashup americans associate
producers are jocelyn gonzalez lindsay
crowderwill sarah pellegrini mary
phillips sandy and shelby sandlin
[Music]
what do boys do oh that's a good that's
different from girls yeah what do boys
do that's different from girls
they pee with their penis
yeah all right
i think we got the biggest thing i think
that's uh
i think that's pretty much
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you